مهرجان وافلام السعوديه العرض الاول
للفيلم الوثائقي قصه ملك الصحافه الذي
يتناول سيره الصحفي السعودي الكبير الراحل
التركي سديري رحمه الله قد تولى سديري
رئاسه التحرير صحيفه الرياض لاكثر من واحد
واربعين عاما
[موسيقى]
الصحافه الرياضيه الى الصحافه الى الكتابه
الى مراحل يعني بيمر في مراحل وايضا
تحريات الوثائقيه تناول جوانب لاول مره
يسلط الضوء عليها في حياه الراحل تركي
السديري كالازمه الصحيه الذهنيه التي تعرض
لها اواخر حياته طبعا الفيلم بوضح لك اياه
ويقدم لا يقدم وجهه نظر فيه ويقدم حقائق
لكل الحق يتوجهه نظر في الراحه الله يرحمه
كما يشاء لكن الفيلم يعطيك حقيقته ولا
يعطيك وجهه نظره فيه ويعطيك معلومات مرت
في بدايه قبل صحيح تحدياته في بدايه عمل
الصحفي في وسط عمله ثم النهايات ورحيله
تفاعل كبير لقاه فيلم قصه ملك الصحافه من
حضور مهرجان افلام السعوديه الذين اكدوا
ان شخصيه الراحل تركي الصديري تستحق مثل
هذا التقدير الفيلم جيد جدا يعني من ناحيه
المهنيه من ناحيه الموثوقيه من ناحيه
الاخراج الاض
واء اعتقد انه متكامل كان في خلق للازمه
خلق
لعلاقه تركي سديري مع الصحافه الورقيه خلق
لعلاقه مع الديجيتال ميديا خلق لحاله
مرضيه
اليوم فقط عرفها الجمهور يعني عبد الرحمن
العصيمي من الظهران العربيه